if you feel you have the right to use
force against me bring guns hi I'm Matt
Welch for recent TV we're here in the
Ronald Reagan Building in Washington DC
for the world premiere of a movie Atlas
Shrugged part 2 we're going to talk to
people about why they're excited in 2012
about Iran's ideas come on in what's
different about part 2 from part 1 the
budget doubled from 10 million 20
million i'm giving you highlights here
Matt we opened up in about 250 theaters
part 1 we're opening up at 815 we looked
at it is here's a way for us to
celebrate Iron Rand's ideas about free
markets and individual achievement and
so I think people will see a film that
really hits those messages quite well we
got a great cast if we have you had
Atlas Shrugged I think the long drought
in the freedom movement between World
War two and Ronald Reagan would have
lasted a lot longer quite interested in
Liberty and the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights and the wonderful country
this could and should be it's pretty
cool because reality looks like fiction
right now
Obama attacking wealth creation saying
you didn't build that and a lot of these
characters come to life to crony
capitalists and all of that so it's a
great time to see Atlas Shrugged part to
the script is crisper more cinematic
although I think it's also true to the
to the ideas I read her in college I was
a socialist at the time my friend it was
really to left them even we both read it
together he loved it and I think you
were out of your mind so why is Iran
important to you David both Iran was one
of the first things i read that made me
a libertarian that passion and the ideas
and the defense of individual rights i
read it when i was very young and made a
real impression on me i read our when I
was in college which was the
surprisingly long time ago and my dad
was a huge fan and I think it was one of
those things that just informed
something about you know what life is
about and then obviously i'm from the
free state project and we're building
galt's gulch and finally why do you
think she's so enduringly controversial
what is it that rankles people of ever
probably because she was right and they
knew it well she's a tough lady and she
does not a doesn't give a lot in an
argument and very unyielding and people
don't really appreciate that especially
in these days when you're not supposed
to judge and I feel like a brand did a
little bit of judging and it's okay
sometimes
or what is john galt is he even a man
all right idea